[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
shoot with the right trigger it's better
to
wait for a weak spot in your enemies
you have some you know okay
shoot with the right story for one shot
okay but you can also build a teacher
but you can also let's try try the
weapon so aim with the left trigger
already the right trigger if you don't
aim with the left trigger and then only
shoot is the pistol and if you keep
pressing the pistol like try it's a six
barrel shots
really powerful and you can mix and
match the pistol the rifle shot with the
melee attack your best friend for melee
attack is the right bumper the small one
try the right small bumper this one
and you can do combo one two three
pistol shots like rifle
and my best advice for you get close to
the enemy and punch them right directly
in the face okay beautiful okay
when you see an enemy growing in yellow
it's a matter for a finish move like
doom style really uh glo glory kill you
know like a
bloudy finish move and in the process
you will regain some health as well okay
so
have fun
it's going down
[Music]
so we got the wednesday rifle going on
right now i'm sorry we got the rifle
action going on right now yeah yeah yeah
and actually you don't have to reload in
the game it's automatically reload all
the weapon
go fight the guy right behind you and
for the people in the room aren't all
podcasts now what's your role on the
game uh so basically i'm the creative
producer on the game i'm here to
speak to journalists i'm able to set the
mood of the game and
and to be sure that the game go in the
right direction during the development
process right now it's looking like it's
going in the right direction
and thank you so much i remember when
you saw it first like this yeah
what are you doing this is this is the
this is the finish
yeah the finish move every time you see
me growing it's your opportunity to
smash him
okay
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i remember seeing this at summer
game fest i was like wow this look looks
absolutely phenomenal it's the lighting
again kind of old west but modern west
yeah with this like we also have this
kind of steampunk elements in the game
because as you can see on the back of jc
the main character
he only have the basic version of the
rifle right now it's like a basic
winchester but at some point you will
meet a really famous character but gonna
give you a coil an electric coil
to infuse your weapon with the power of
electricity wow think about your uh
electricity electricity on your gauntlet
on your rifle as well on your pistol
every tool will be like electricity
infused and really powerful with much
higher aoe effects and it's really cool
this is really cool absolutely so we got
a little confrontation right now yeah
you can also destroy the balcony by
shooting on it if you want to uncover
these
nasty bastards
you know he shoots right into the cycle
so it's a one shot nice and my advice
for this guy go melee
may like go melee
as you can
yeah nice nice destruction okay okay
yeah yeah yeah
get close get closer yeah get close use
the pistol as well
nice nice nice
jump there you see three shots on the
mini okay okay
nice nice sometimes a lot of destruction
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
wow
okay we're really almost getting into
like a fatality
almost situation with these punishing
mechanics on it you know one thing that
i like about it like the visceral nature
very
you can be up close and personal or you
could stay distance and fighting what
are some of the inspirations you know as
far as the fighting system yeah
oh nice one combo is crazy and you and
elf goes back so it's better to perform
this kind of finish move so the
inspiration
are really clear for the game the team
really wants to really love like god of
war for you know the tanky really
really punchy like uh
like a snappy action game god of war is
one of the main inspiration but also the
stylish combat it's all about style from
a game like diva maker
make right so think about a mix like god
of war maybe even may cry of course old
western movies
red dead as well but it's not so much
close as red dead where there's it's a
slow-paced game at some point this one
you are right directly into the action
directly you feel really powerful in the
first level this is the second level of
the game level two yeah only the tip of
the iceberg of the game because
after that you will unlock a parry like
the ability to grab enemies right
right into your face to smash them
gotcha so as you progress and we're
looking at like it seems like the
character gets to enhance his skill set
gets to to get more moves more abilities
yeah so is there like going to be like a
full french kind of skill tree of course
you will see this
and there's a little twist on the
thailand tree talon tree sorry
because on the demo we only showcase the
melee talent tree right but expect
talentry dedicated to the weapon as well
nice nice love the expansion love the
versatility of that and you can
basically choose your place now of
course really cool of course you're
riding down here in this train it's
amazing and this is the the dark twist
of the level
because we ended up like on this mine
this is
classic with some spiders you have some
hint like oh there's gonna something not
so great on the on the area
and as you can see the game will turn
into some spooky one after that so this
is the
and you will see some
a feature in the game it's called the
glamour okay and the glamour is the tool
from for the vampire to add themselves
to the eye of the human right so
the vampire the game don't really want
to be like uh
on the sun as well because they're a
vampire so they hide themselves on the
ground
and they keep themselves hiding between
behind sorry this kind of illusionary
walls
and in this cutscene jesse
will understand like oh there's
something wrong here
with the with the little rock like oh
there's a glass thing right here now one
thing i'm a huge fan of rock on there's
a huge fan of over the shoulder
cinematic storytelling cinematic
storytelling one thing off the bat
the evil that seems to fit the mold yeah
expect cinematic on each level of the
game during gameplay but we don't want
to cut the gameplay every time so you
will have schematic at the beginning of
the level ending sometime in the middle
of the level to set the mood to set the
story we have great character this is
jesse you also have edgar the sidekick
of jessie okay which is also playable if
you want to play co-op
you can't just jump yeah
you are the full co-op mode in the game
two-player full
call
the story mode wow it's split screen or
multiplayer you have online call out how
about the mind yeah
yeah i'm
selfish oh you just dropped the ball i
had no idea even west was cool
it's co-op game that's right
it's cool
yeah sorry
that's what i want from them
i'll be a message
what do you think about the gameplay the
gameplay like i said it feels like
it does have that that feeling and
heaviness of god of war yeah and then it
but it feels like a gears game as well
like you know gears feels heavy right
this does not feel like yeah really
it's very nimble more like a lot more
nimble
i love the changing up between different
types of guns and the melee because it
just makes the it makes the combat very
kinetic
um yeah
i'm really enjoying this yeah totally my
type of game now let's talk development
how long has evil last been in
development at this point it's a
two and a half year project
we expect to release the game later this
year okay on all the platforms so pc
ps5 ps4 as well xbox theory x and s xbox
one as well
so yeah
at this point we really want to polish
the game
not to not to announce a release date
right now
you know the industry yes yeah you know
the you know taking your time you rather
yeah pc2 you see as well this is the pc
business
pc i don't know if you can answer it
right now if you can't that's okay um i
was gonna ask about steam deck is this
something that you might consider in the
future if it's not in the plans right
now it's a really good question i think
i don't have the answer at this point
i don't have the i hope so i have to ask
the guy on the technical side of the
game because you know on steam deck you
have some limitations
you have some like hardware limitations
but the game will run as you can see the
game runs smoothly right now on pc and
it's already so speaking of talentry
this is the envelope
and i invite you to like to have a sneak
peek of the
the the most advanced talent tree
every attack this is the monetary like
area of effect electricity grabbing
attack
this is really very powerful
very extensive type of games thrive yeah
variety in the combat and it allows you
to play the game the way you want really
yeah that's the that's the point of the
cash you lose in the game you invest the
cash to unlock talents
this is awesome i i love i could chase
off that diversity of the gameplay i'm
also seeing a lower tab at the top as
well yeah you know and that was that
like collectibles things you find again
you can go there
press that right button
after you check this yeah pick the first
talent pick your talent pick the first
one by keep pressing the a button on the
talent part
and the law but today we will collect
some stuff like this tattoo these two
documents okay and we also have like a
proper codex for every character enemy
and every level of the game this is the
first level you have a spoiler for the
first level
now again as far as like length and
levels um how long will a player
anticipate playing even less before
complete how long is the game
at this point we expect something
more like 16 hours
16 to 17. it depends really depends on
your skill it really depends the way to
play we also have difficulty levels as
well this is a normal mode for the demo
for the packs is better for
for for the audience for everyone but
you also have an evil difficulty level
so if you really want to challenge
yourself yeah they can rack it up yeah
nice nice so we're continuing on through
the level what are these spiky things
but we're going to keep going so the
spiky thing are some cages and you can
actually
throw enemies in the cages to instant
kill them to really use the environment
yeah and you can try to do it at some
point to do that you have to perform you
have to press a and punch at the same
time
to do some like voting attack it's so
powerful this is cool we are actually
fighting some flying enemies some flying
enemies so these little guys are are
here to learn the player or to use the
weak points because you see some glowing
cycles if you shoot them during the
cycle it's a one shot gotcha okay gosh
that's pretty cool now forrest is um his
bar his menu system yeah lower left i'm
seeing the two unlocks now these two
things right there what what potentially
could those be on one of them maybe
because we are on the second level of
the game of course jesse don't have the
full the full tools
on it but it will unlock many many tools
like on the third one the top
the anti-top slot will be a shotgun
you have a short gun on cooldown but
small cooldown
at this point you have to turn back okay
right here go down take the stair right
go down take the stair climb the liver
so you will have a shotgun you will have
a crossbow
flamethrower flamethrower frame for
dynamite oh dynamites
and i don't want to spoil all the people
but also on the right part of the screen
jesse with the institute the raunchy
institute it's like you know like james
bond gadgets
yes you okay jesse we have this new
space species story of empire i give you
this cross infused with lightning to
like stun enemy in area
aoe effect with some tools on the ground
again extremely ambitious this is
extremely ambitious
absolutely yeah yeah
yeah it works yeah
okay cool yeah trunk practice up and
shoot the plank right here
yeah yeah yeah it's not so clear we have
to change a little bit the level design
yeah really
really and it's good and it's good to
have it in the packs because we see
people like stuck on this specific point
so but we have time to change it so it's
perfect that's the feedback that
positive feedback yeah for the entrance
to the temple we're moving and grooving
almost there hopefully some can get to
this end of this level if you can
that'll be great he's pushing through
so cool
nice
this is so nice i think this is one of
the most like
crazy area we have for this level
because you have this vibrant red
like it's like really cloudy like it
said the mood so well with the the
inverted pyramid on the on the
background it's so cool the
environmental design yeah and the stage
design like really and the sound design
is really you have to you have to hear
the sound design of the punch it's so
cool
it's not so cool and with these
different levels of stuff
i love that you can see a little bit of
diversity in the biome you're seeing
like i said you went from the outside
kind of wah
but i love when you go into a level like
this it's darker you see the reds and
the kids every time the theme is very
the idea behind every level of the game
is to
surprise the player like you enter a
forest it's like a proper forest maybe
set in the night with a full moon
at some point before you you find some
kind of a big temple okay right in the
middle of the forest
what is it what is this it's not
expected at all and we have some classic
stuff like a canyon stuff like you know
but we've always a twist okay always
a twist now i see those spikes in there
couldn't solve use those spikes and
throw them into that thing you can try
you can try you can try it all right
let's try to win yeah it's like
a plus punch
on the but these are some tanky enemy
they are heavier
yeah it's tougher to perform but you can
try it it works
good dodge good roll let's get that
actually it's doing well because the
boss is just after this fight
we gotta see the airport before we go
you can also try the pistol for this guy
because this is a small area pistol is
so great for this kind of situation
oh man they take a lot of gas yeah
okay let's go let the screen go off no
no or not yeah
just when i'm saying it say the battery
yeah continue
all right cool
good good
nice oh finish
belief for justin
of course
that's the point
if you want to be the pro player of the
day try to press to press the right
trigger on this one you perform a kick
it can interrupt
yeah nice and it's for life nice get
that health back yeah let's go so you
gotta see that ball and this poor last
one is like
watchman
on each corner of the room nice one two
three and the last one and the door
right
you see the the big entrance the red
entrance yeah ah in video game it means
do you think of ambulances yeah
a confrontation
maybe
a possibility of a possibility of
confrontation maybe maybe over i don't
know maybe there's a room maybe a
relaxing time you know
with great food
this is a restaurant
yeah maybe a restaurant
maybe a bus
oh no oh no they're trying to stop you
to get me and you see the pace of the
game it's like frantic yeah like it's so
enjoyable to play that you want to fight
in this game yeah the combat is
everything yeah
let's go let's get in there we're going
we're going
we're almost there
out of marsdale yeah this is it so
pulling that thing down
getting over the plank
to the ominous red door with nothing but
good things that happens
nothing but be careful not to fall
on the boss
and that's it
i mean try you your bets
on the let's let's have a bet for this
one
i guess how long to try two tracks only
to try because it's good yeah all right
maybe one
high pressure high technically high
closing all the effects
so the trick on this boss is totally
immune to range attack you have to you
have to punch him
except that's one point
but you will figure it figure it out
sorry
this is very small
yeah
yeah the boss has the main challenge
yeah
look at the enemy design the character
design it's really really impressive
this is what i like to see from the soul
shower yeah
like i want the visual representation i
shouldn't say that's wrong
this is this is one of the vampire
commander
except some crazy design because it's
like the most like little vampire we
have we also have some kind of
werewolves okay okay we're gonna fall
into a man much much bigger creatures
nice
this is um it's a baby the vampire
he's low on the total phone he's a baby
on the bike fighting in a pool of blood
in the pool of blood yeah of course
oh no
no
so this is this is the first try you
have a second one okay
does he keep the same health or is it
though sorry i just did it regenerate or
not yeah no no he back he backed the
full shirt you wouldn't see it
there's a twist that's 50 percent
yeah he flies
yeah perfect
this is the pin the punish movement like
this is the best that i can finish him
let's go
oh oh he acted up yeah
yeah
let's go
this looks stunning look at the bats
look at the bass bro this looks crazy
getting there we gotta get a 50 cent
i heard you get wild i think it's gonna
be mad the box like
what's the guy who is the guy
perfect
and be careful right now shoot him shoot
him three times one
two three because if he if he don't
shoot the bus regain all the life oh no
yeah oh that's like a healing phase this
is the eating phase for the boss so you
have to be careful really careful right
now and some minions
going with the party oh no here we go
shoot the ball shoot the boss
yeah do not let him do that healing
should should shoot perfect nice i love
this mechanic this is fire
it's perfect don't get scoot here we go
yeah when he do that you gotta stop him
from there
and you can kill the minions yeah nice
with the punch it's perfect they are
weak
okay
we don't like
there we go
you can yeah it's a life orbs
if you want to regen little bits yeah
let's get there
next time
but he's doing great he's going really
good yeah
wow
two try will be enough for this guy one
one two
three
perfect perfect get himself
let's go
and you also have a knife on the floor
on the floor if you want to on the floor
like finish him perfect for the finisher
one two three
nice try hello
perfect you finish the demo you finish
the builder
excellent what do you think about the
game no no no when can i have this
soon
[Applause]
[Music]
and the vampire is actually still alive
even with the curtain yeah
there's some nasty nasty
species of vampires you know what it is
it's not often you get a new ip that
feels just so like like you're engaged
already yeah character i love the world
already
yeah so we just wrapped up
an amazing demo and an
amazing show for this guy the old man
can still play an amazing playthrough
yes yes absolutely stunning
the people i have to say we i think we
saved the best for land this is the very
last interview for us at pax east
evil west is clearly high in law
broadcasting foods right now absolutely
and again just for emphasis
how far along are we platforms and where
can people go to get as much information
on evil yeah we expect to release the
game later this year on all platforms
basically so ps5 ps4 xbox series s x
xbox one pc as well
so yeah i hope you enjoy it i hope
you're ready so
it is
again it takes all the things that i
love about gears
yeah
people's adam live gears i love gear you
love me
god of war it just feels like that type
of over-the-shoulder third-person action
game but it's a lot more kinetic and
like you said the movement it's quick
the gameplay is frantic you're
constantly getting bombarded by enemies
yeah and especially i noticed like when
you're in
going to a boss
is just as dangerous as when you get
into them yes yes and
when you see in the in the boss fight in
the demo the bosses have so much
personality uh it just it this this game
oozes with just that personality
personality yeah
amazing action it just feels great it
feels like it's ready
and we cook so much stuff for the game
so much turf i invite you to watch the
last trailer for the game because we
will see much way much more weapons
much more environments as well on the
game so yeah thank you for all the
complaints today no absolutely thank you
amazing to have you today on the booth
time one of the most highly anticipated
titles here at pax
evil bless
y'all check it out
[Music]
you